should you detour from your dream I'm
going to answer that question in today's
episode of ask Evan so recent gotta ask
another question from one of my YouTube
audience love you guys Vanessa who wrote
in the say hi haven't just found out
about you and your videos and I'm loving
it great job thanks Vanessa now I have a
question about hard times that I've been
facing lately how do you know if a
detour if it's part of the process of
reaching your dream or a path you
shouldn't take because it's not related
to the process of reaching your dreams
you see I've already did what you just
said not to do I've spent all my money
and put my full-time efforts in to
create an online business and it didn't
work now my situation is worse ever no
money left literally debts living with
my mom and then your stock but you can't
give up I think like that but I tend to
procrastinate and say I'm not giving up
I'm not going to do it later now I need
a job and it's true we need to make a
living even while working towards our
dreams pay the bill survive and so on
but taking a job now that's not my dream
job seems like a detour to me so should
i do it could the d to be a part of the
way or not because i also know that i
won't be happy anymore with anything
less than what i want so Vanessa I'm
feeling your pain I'm feeling the
sacrifice that you went into your
business and I'm going to give you three
strategies to help you stay on path
number one is follow your flow the most
important bit of advice I can give you i
think is to follow your flow and if
there's something that you really love
doing something that you're being pulled
towards trying then you got to go for
even if it doesn't make any sense right
now following your flow will help make
sure that you're always excited by your
business always happy with what you're
doing and always leads you to creating
something of importance every time I
follow my flow in trying wanting to try
something new it's always led to
something either great or at least
something that I now don't have any
regrets doing so one example is making
this YouTube channel right I thought hey
I'm going to make you to channel i'm
curious about i'm going to follow my
flow and go into it and now it's become
a major part of what i'm doing and
there's an other projects that I've
tried and I didn't love and I dropped
them but now I don't live with regret
knowing that I didn't give it my all to
at least try and know if
got an answer or not so follow your flow
number two is work to learn the reason
to get a job most people think is just
to make money and yes you have to pay
your bills you have to pay your rent you
want to be able to move out of your
house and not live with your mom anymore
and I get that and it's hard and you're
struggling and that can be okay to go
get a job but the reason to get a job is
to learn you work to learn you want to
work at a business where ideally you can
learn how to be a better entrepreneur
don't just get a job flipping burgers
just to make some money go get a job
where you're going to learn something
from somebody and ideally what I try to
do is find a company that has 10
employees or less somebody doing exactly
what you want to do and go off for the
work for them and get as close to the
entrepreneur founder as possible and
take on as many responsibilities as
possible not just doing what you were
hired to do try to get as close to the
entrepreneur founders possible and take
on as many responsibilities as you can
because that's going to teach you how to
run a successful business so that when
you go when you launch your business
again you have more Skills and this way
you're getting paid to do it right
you're getting paid to make mistakes
you're getting paid to learn you're
getting paid to understand how your
industry works and make contacts and
it's a fantastic way to do it while not
risking everything like you did the
first time around right so go get a job
if you need to get a job that's totally
okay I'm not the guy who says go all in
and start your business and burn all
your savings because then you end up in
the situation that you're in now so good
get it go get a job but don't see that
as a detour use that job as an
opportunity to learn and to grow and
understand how your industry works and
number three is don't let your dream die
you know if this is a big dream of yours
to start your own business as online
company or whatever it is that you want
to start up don't let it die start on
the side start part-time yes you go and
get this job and you're making some
money and you're able to move out of
your mom's house but don't let that hold
you back from saying well I tried my
business and it didn't work out start
part-time that's totally okay right but
make sure you're dedicating some time to
it because a lot of entrepreneurs after
they try the first time they say I'm not
preneur I'm never going to make this
work I don't know how to do this and
they let their dream die right there on
the table and the funny fact is most
entrepreneurs they don't make it the
first time around they've had a lot of
failures before they find the idea and
they have the experience it helps hit
them you know into the big links with a
home run so spend time every day on your
business at least half an hour every
single day no excuses half an hour at
least bare minimum every day focusing on
your dream to keeping it alive and as
you start making some progress in making
some money with your business ideal you
quit your job to the point where you
feel like I'm not learn anything new at
my job anymore and I'm making enough
money from my own business now to
support myself maybe not live a huge
life of luxury and you know buy new cars
and get a big house but enough to
support yourself so you know you're not
gonna have to go back and move in with
your mom again so remember follow your
flow work to learn and don't let your
dream die thank you so much for watching
I love to know how you guys have handled
that situation share your your your
deepest story of failure i guess in the
comments below and how you overcame it
i'm going to join in the discussion and
i look forward to hearing from you thank
you guys so much for watching continue
to believe and i'll see you soon oh and
don't forget if you have a question that
you want be an answer in the next
episode of ask Evan leave it below and
I'll see what I can do